My name is Sarah Meyer, and I am
a web developer from New York, specifically
Brooklyn,
home of -- yeah, home of the world's finest
JavaScript
meet-up, the very famous Brooklyn JS, not
to knock the
other JS.
Here we go.
So my computer is ... Uh-huh
... Okay.
You know, you would expect a lot of things
when you're about to do a talk.
The last thing you
expect is your computer to just shut down
on you.
But
these things happen.
And okay.
Yay!
All right.
applause].
All right, right back to it.
So, I'm going
to talk basically about being the only engineer
in
a non-technical organisation, and, you know,
this could
because you're a consultant working with a
company that
has no technical expertise, or it could because
you're
the only engineer on salary at a company that
maybe has
like outsource developers.
And I'm just going to
explain a little bit about how I came to that
position
and what I did with it.
So yet again, I'm Sarah
Saltic-Meyer, hit me up on Twitter: Meyerini.
And
I started out at a tech company where more
than
50 per cent of the staff were software engineers.
And
you know, we were a pretty cool.
Web development
company in 2013, so we were on that backbone
in rails,
you know, Ts all about the monolithic MVC
single page
app, and, you know, that's where I sort of
grew up as an
engineer.
That's where I learned best practices and
where I, you know, kind of absorbed what software
engineering was, which was like constant refactoring.
You know, always pushing for technical excellent,
well
tested code.
All the good things that we come and talk
about at conferences like this, and it was
a particular
kind of culture, like video games.
We didn't work at
all on the day when Apple would do a developer
conference, because there are things that
are more
important in life, and I loved it there.
That was
a company in Boston, and I really wanted to
go back to
New York, which is where I grew up.
So I did that, sort
of ran away, you know, took a job for the
sake of taking
a job, which was, you know, kind of a terrible
idea in
a sense because I almost immediately got coached
by the
company of my dreams, I felt really connected
to the
product, not so much a technical product,
but just
having the opportunity to work on it.
I couldn't turn
it down, didn't turn it down.
So in this non-technical
organisation there was suddenly one technical
person and
that was me.
So, you know, what did I do there, and
what do you do there?
It was another single page app
this time because it was 2014 where were on
to angular,
and we had -- it was an e-commerce that had
a big
loading spinner every time you got there,
and I hated
that.
I thought there was so much to be done to
improve
it, and so I wanted us to move to service
side rendering
of our pages, I wanted us to get away from
angular and
rendering and that was one of my first things,
looking
through the app, figuring out what test coverage
was
necessary, and what -- you know, if there
were better
ways that we could be rendering our templates,
like
anything that was in Hamil C, maybe, should
have been in
Hamil.
A lot of what I did there, because it was
a non-technical organisation again, we had
print
designers doing our web design, which resulted
in some
very beautiful pages, but if you have ever
fought the
battle of -- well, the mobile design looks
like things
as you have elements A, B and C, and then
on the desktop
designs it is elements C, B and A, then you
know of my
struggle at this company.
(Laughter) . It was a lot
of: gosh, well, we can make it look prettier
at this
great point, and at this point, but anywhere
in between
we are utterly screwed and no one has considered
this.
Also, you know, one of the things when you
are at
a non-technical company, you're probably not
going to
get to work on big projects, interesting projects,
the
kind of projects that get you up in the morning
as an
engineer.
You know, when you're taking something and
building a web framework that has never been
built
before, you're not solving problems that have
never been
solved before; you're building landing pages
for -- to
sell make-up, and I wanted to do that because
I identified with that product.
But it wasn't
engineering; it was web design.
And I think generally,
when you are the only person making these
decisions, you
don't get to choose, basically.
So how did I respond to
this?
I got more productive than I'd ever been in
my
life before.
I used to be a lazy developer, but I think
a lot of us fall into software engineering,
because it
is a pretty reliable line of work.
I've responded to
being the only person who could fix things
by purely
trying to fix them, getting up every day and
working on
weekends, and I also -- we had lunch & learns
at this
company, and I hosted about three or four
lunch & learns
on web development, and I got the social media
manager
and the executive assistant building their
own personal
websites and HTML and CSS, and this was was
the most
gratifying thing possible, building empathy
for software
engineering by making it more of my kind around
me.
So
if you have opportunity to do that, this is
possible,
you know, maybe not for consultants who are
working, but
definitely possible if you are a salary employee
working
in the same physical location as these non-technical
staff members.
You know, there is an engineer inside
everyone just waiting to come out.
And a lot of people
recognise that engineering is sort of a better
thing
than the one they may have, and there may
be people on
your customer support team or on your marketing
team who
really want what you have, which is the skills
that got
you into the job that you have.
And, you know, seek
them out and use them.
So you're also now, when you are
the only engineer, you're the only champion
that
technology has.
You know, if you come from
a traditional engineering environment, whoever
the sort
of top engineer is, you know, your CTO, your
VP of
engineering, that person's job in addition
to making
decisions and managing the day-to-day work
of the
department, they are always advocating for
technology
to, you know, your C-level team or your owner
of the
business.
And so if you have a powerful CTL, then
that's somebody who can take the time to say,
"Well we
need to spend a week writing tests for this,
or we spend
to spend a month refactoring our order service."
If you
don't have somebody like that as a buffer
between you
and management, then you are suddenly the
buffer.
You
are both the engine and the buffer between
the engine
and what's trying to make the engine work.
So you need
a) to really really work on your communication
skills,
and (b), you need to have a certain amount
of like
gravitas and weight within the company.
Basically, that
upper management needs to trust you that you're
not just
fucking around when you say, "I need more
time to do
this, to do it right."
And if they don't trust you,
then you will not get that time, and your
product will
suffer for it.
Pretty much inevitably.
On the other hand, there is a huge bright
side which
is that as if you were the only engineer,
nobody is
going to teach you how to be a better engineer
at that
company.
So much of what we do as engineers on a team
is the kind of unacknowledged labour of tutoring
other
developers, and this happens pretty much automatically
when you're working next to somebody who does
a similar
thing to you, even the most junior developer
and the
most senior, the intersection, the diagram
of their
knowledge is not the total sum of their knowledge,
but
two people together know more than any one
person could.
And so basically, by osmosis, turning to somebody
and
saying "how do I do this?", and obviously
things like
you're slack, you're IRAC, you end up learning
quite
a bit, but when you're the only engineer,
you don't have
that.
So maybe you get good at spreadsheets, because
spreadsheets are the way your company communicates
with
each other.
This was the case with me; if it didn't
exist in a spreadsheet, it wasn't real.
Or maybe you
get really good at e-mails or maybe try to
spend a lot
of time with that print designer who is actually
really
good at their job and understands colour and
spacing in
a way that you never will.
But, you know, you can learn
from them, you can learn from that, and you
should.
Because it is the most you are going to get
in terms of
skill growth.
We've all been there, sort of a solitary
developer with stack overflow as their only
real friend.
You always have stack overflow but that's
never where
you're going to do most of your skill.
If you for
instance want -- like I did -- to learn how
to deal with
problems of scale, which are some of the most
interesting at a web development company,
then you're
not going to have the chance to do that as
sort of
a lone wolf.
Anything that you can teach yourself,
you'll learn, and anything that cannot be
taught by
other people, you will not learn.
So, you know, I felt very isolated a lot of
the time
until something happened to me, which is that
I started
going to meet-ups.
And the first time I got on the
Brooklyn JS slack channel, it was like a revelation,
there were cat gifts flying back and forth
again, there
were JavaScript and functional programming
jokes which
are all terrible but they're the jokes we
have, and we
love them.
So it turned out that as isolated as I felt
there, I was really in the centre of a much
larger
universe of developers in New York.
There were
literally hundreds of people around me who
I could go to
for the sense of community, and sort of growth
opportunities that I needed as a developer.
When you
experience stagnation, actually, even if you
are in the
middle of a large engineering team and start
to feel
you're become stagnated, well guys, go to
a meet-up.
You're already here, so I can't tell you to
go to a
conference, you clearly learned that trick,
but there
are people out there who will actually, just
for love
and not for money, do the work of teaching
you.
Do the
work of supporting you.
Do the work of being your
friend, which is work, and actually, when
you were at
a company, that's part of what you're getting
paid to
do, secretly.
The last thing is that if you were the only
engineer
at a company, if you were only the technical
person,
don't be scared to leave.
I didn't get into that job
because I wanted to be the only engineer at
that company
forever.
I wanted there to be more of me.
And when --
how do you get more engineers besides helping
the social
media manager build her own website?
You hire them.
One of the most important things when you're
at a small
company is whether you have any authority
in the hiring
process, whether candidates that you bring
to your
bosses will be considered, and whether you
get any, you
know, yes or no input on candidates.
If you don't have
either of those things, you should consider
what kind of
company or culture you're in, and as the realisation
that slowly caught up to me when after six
months of
being the only person there, I still was the
only person
there, decided that it wasn't for me after
all, being
the lone wolf.
So I left.
I went to another big
engineering company in New York, a 60-person
developer
team.
I am happy to say I have everything I could
want
in a job there, but the knowledge of what
will happen,
the knowledge of what I will face if I ever
go into the
situation again, if I decided to start my
own start-up,
or decided to be the CTO or the founding technical
member of the team, it is all going to happen
again, the
struggles are going to be the same, and in
some ways
they'll be even worse, but I know what they
are now, so
I'm not scared.
Thank you.